but first tonight democrats are once
again poised to spend a massive huge
monumental amount of your money and as
of now one senator stands in their way
the last democrat with a backbone is it
going to be kristin cinema time will
tell now if she does ultimately cave the
schumann mansion 500 billion dollar
green new deal energy spending spree
that they purposely
label as something it's not the
inflation reduction act will become the
law of the land and in less than two
years democrats will have added an
additional four trillion dollars in new
spending four trillion and that includes
two trillion dollars a bailout to blue
states like california new york 1.1
trillion for their green new deal
projects and so-called green
infrastructure and now another 500
billion to appease the climate religious
cult that rules the democratic party but
make no mistake despite its name the
inflation reduction act does not reduce
inflation and it will not bring down
costs for anybody in fact look at forbes
quote for example on net this proposal
is a recipe for worsening inflation and
persistent economic stagnation the
nonpartisan tax foundation also
determined quote by reducing long-run
economic growth the bill worsens
inflation by constraining the productive
capacity of our economy the university
of pennsylvania wharton budget model
found that this bill will increase
america's inflation rate over the next
two years and get this report from the
nonpartisan joint committee on taxation
they have even determined that a
majority of the tax costs from this bill
will be borne by households earning less
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year oh i remember the president
promising again and again and again he
wouldn't raise taxes on people that made
uh under four hundred 000. well guess
what
under this bill people making under 200
000 a year they will pay
16.7 billion dollars in new taxes in
year one and pretty much the same amount
in year two corporations small
businesses especially those in the
manufacturing sector they're going to
also get hit hard with higher taxes a
cost that they will pass on to you the
consumer how many times do we have to
remind you corporations don't pay taxes
people do they pass the cost unto us and
that's not all in order to squeeze we
you the american people well some more
this bill also will more than double the
size of the irs so that everyone can
experience the joy of an annual tax
audit in other words you'll get the
hannity treatment because they just pull
my file as a matter of just general
practices anyway as a result the
inflation reduction act the big lie will
increase inflation it will lower growth
ultimately eliminate 30 000 private
sector jobs according to the tax
foundation why would anyone in their
right mind support this bill especially
now in the middle of a recession senator
manchin care to explain take a look
four hundred thousand dollars and below
now are going to be taxed their taxes
are going to go up that's a lie that is
a pure outright lie so their taxes are
not going to go up not at all and i want
to hit that
line again
are you saying that mitch mcconnell and
others in the senate are wrong about
those numbers and that americans taxes
are not going to go up beyond that
totally absolutely wrong totally wrong
uh fact check harris faulkner was right
16.7 billion dollars year one people
making under 200 000 a year uh joe
manchin clearly either doesn't know
what's in his own bill or doesn't want
you to trust the nonpartisan experts at
the wharton business school or the joint
committee on taxation or the tax
foundation they're all wrong but he's
right uh no uh harris was right and so
were the three uh groups we just
mentioned he's asking you to put your
faith in joe biden and the democratic
socialist party after all why would
democrats ever lie to us let's see the
same democrats the promised inflation
was transitory the same people that
swore that trillions of dollars in new
spending could not cause inflation the
same people that claim that the united
states is not really in a recession
despite by definition two consecutive
quarters of negative growth the same
democrats who stopped oil and gas
exploration in the atlantic ocean
pacific ocean anwar other federal lands
the ones that killed the keystone xl
pipeline and then told you that this
would not have an impact on gas prices
and also gave a waiver to vladimir putin
so he could build his nordstream 2
pipeline and then when gas prices did
spike the same democrats told you to go
out and buy an electric car by the way
that car on average is 20 grand more
than a gas fueled automobile and charged
on a grid powered 88 by fossil fuels
with a battery produced from mining
specific minerals from mother earth now
these are the people that joe manchin
has chosen to trust because joe manchin
is a typical democrat he tried to
masquerade as a moderate he let the
people of west virginia down and by the
way the coal industry in particular will
be hurt hard by this bill but he's more
than happy to tow the party line
especially after schumer oh look at this
they sweetened the deal amazing the
things that go on in the swamp in
washington he promised to green light a
pipeline project
from one of mansion's major donors from
west virginia to virginia now in reality
no actual moderate would ever support
this green new deal energy spending bill
for any reason it is totally and
completely reckless and irresponsible we
did invite senator manchin on this
program to defend his position his
office didn't respond to our request
now he did every sunday show why not
come on here joe just a few minutes of
your time is all we ask now it's a
massive betrayal to the people of west
virginia their lives will get worse
their taxes will go up the cost of
living will continue to rise and for
what three billion dollars to convert
post office post office trucks into
electric vehicles two billion dollars
for environmental justice grants
whatever that means 80 billion for 87
000 new irs agents a boatload of money
for inefficient solar panels and wind
turbines that by the way won't even put
a a dent in our energy grid and by the
way americans still suffer because of
this bill but congratulations joe
manchin you're making bernie sanders and
aoc very happy tonight hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else